so after smorgasbord la Justin and I of
course being Korean you know we kicked
it around for a little bit and we of
course wanted to get dope as food which
is definitely provided in k-town and
also a couple of drinks because it's in
our blood so we're back over here at
this undisclosed drinking place in
k-town now one of the most fun things to
do in k-town is to drink and drink with
your friends and so we're over here at
undisclosed location and we're about to
have a fun [ __ ] time what do you
think abso-fucking-lutely check out this
penis on the [ __ ] wall if you don't
know already
Korean people drink a lot me
specifically I'm not that big of a
drinker anymore it's not my thing but
every now and then I will have some
drinks with some friends so Koreans
drinking culture is hugeness we're
considered like the the Irish of Asia
it's done as a friendship thing as a
camaraderie thing people typically do it
after work with their bosses and their
co-workers it's just something that if
you are Korean you're basically gonna
drink usually the younger person pours
it for the older person right I am the
younger one
so traditionally this is sort of fun two
hands right you pour it as such from
what I remember I don't remember too
much and then we want just a little bit
ahead when I drink it I can't look at
him I suppose to be ashamed of myself
like we're Korean tradition where the
younger person can't look at the older
person in Tucson and then I turn away
like a little [ __ ] so once we got
settled in of course if we're gonna have
Korean liquor we have to have Anju now
if you don't know what Anju is and you
would basically Korean bar food and I
don't think I've ever had a situation
where I was drinking something at a
Korean bar and I didn't have some
bomb-ass food with it as well so here we
are we're talking about corn cheese car
cheese so cheese corn this right here is
like quintessentially a Korean American
drinking bar food so if you want to talk
about the ingredient of what corn cheese
is it's going to be canned corn it's
gonna be mayonnaise it's gonna be some
string yes mozzarella put into a broiler
now I know that sounds [ __ ]
disgusting as [ __ ] but this is one of my
favorite bar foods of all time not
healthy at all whatsoever it's salty and
sweet instead a whole play on that this
is like definitively what like ethnic
American food is it's not American it's
not Korean it's something nice for Chi
it's [ __ ] corn cheese next up another
favorite when it comes to Korean
drinking bar food we have our classic
KFC which is Korean fried chicken my
friends here we go nice and crispy you
take this sweets you know what you don't
want to bastardize it with the sauce yet
first you want to try it in its plain
glory
that's [ __ ] yo they make a good for
particular you know at this undisclosed
location oh it's still nice and warm
like a nice vagina its moist and crispy
on the outside like a nice vagina
well yeah typically when you go to these
crane bars and you get your chicken
wings you can order it two different
ways
dry as [ __ ] or you can get it with the
young M sauce which is denim is like
it's like seasoning flavor right
typically it's going to have that that
sweet spicy play on it every every bar
or restaurant has their own flavor this
one here is a little bit more on the
spicy side which I personally like it's
not as sweet a little bit more savory
but the reason why I like to have the
sauce on the side is because if you have
a chicken we're sitting around and the
sauce is already on it it's gonna start
to get soggy
I want the crunch I want the crisp I
want that right there chicken oh wow
this is good I'm really surprised that
how great of a chicken wing this place
makes at this undisclosed location next
up we have another classic dish I don't
really call this a drinking dish per se
but everybody loves it
this is called kimchi Johnson when you
have something called a pajeon it's like
I guess if you wanted to describe we
call it what Korean pancake yeah so
you'll see it typically out of here in
k-town to do what I like on a hot
griddle it'll come out nice and crispy
on the bottom so once again we're over
here we're eating this delicious dish at
a place that's undisclosed it's probably
one of the best things I've ever had in
my [ __ ] life but we can't talk about
it you know what we can do though is
take a shot of this [ __ ]
oh yeah sure let's talk about how good
this undisclosed showed you is slice no
Cheers
oh yeah cool thing about Korean culture
and like especially like bar food or
food and generally in these type of
situations you order enough food you get
something called
puppy food and thermos is exactly what
you think it's service pretty much if
you order a lot of stuff or your regular
at a place they give you [ __ ] for free
so right now we got some free [ __ ] and
it is this chicken gizzard fried they
gave us a [ __ ] because they thought we
would eat it we [ __ ] love that [ __ ]
this is chicken butthole but it tastes
so good
mmm-hmm the Korean name for this is
captainship
right the literal translation of taco
devious chicken [ __ ] house this here is
called soo that that's blood sausage
they take like a intestinal lining they
stuff like rice and noodles and blood
and all they cook it this is la poking
and this is a like instant ramen with
like rice cake egg you know Oden and
it's in like a gochujang sauce for
people out there that aren't Korean or
haven't gotten to Korean bars I know it
might be a weird closet for you cuz
you're thinking you know why would
people give you free food if you have
the money to buy more food well that
type of thing in Korean culture
specifically in this like bar food
culture is so that we develop a
relationship with our customers so they
continue to come back and I just think
it's like great business tactics what
about gang it has something to do with
Enki what was it Alex Ikki game 'pinkie
game that's exactly what it's called we
have Vanessa being the moderator here
the lovely Vanessa and of course we're
going to have a few people drink with us
as well but alex is going to take over
the drinks for Sasha and Mariel because
they're the designated drivers and we
drink responsibly over here and Justin
here is probably gonna get [ __ ]
yeah so we play the drinking game it's
basically the Korean version of never
have I ever
and you you're going to point out the
person who you think is most likely to
do this type of thing first assumption
this person is most likely to have
watched the most porn three to one point
hahaha
I put into david awkward david first of
all can we defend ourselves let's talk
about this for a second we have been
open about this on just getting news
just in game number one porn is so
[ __ ] boring um i haven't watched it
avidly in years back in the day maybe
cuz we're bagging the import was hard to
get it was super exciting you had to
like get a piece of paper from a friend
that told you about a friend who might
have it and you give them a quarter to
give you a piece of paper it's just so
accessible i don't watch it that much
since you block and don't what are you
that you did not and everyone point
ideas are you take a shot [ __ ] this app
because it kept on asking us like these
very sexually suggestive questions and
which by the way i didn't appreciate
that not only did my girlfriend point me
out to be the one to drink but justin
and everybody else to I think the two
people that were attack the most was me
adjusted [ __ ]
this person is most likely to be a
member of a royal
one point what I wanted the boy I wonder
the great I'm not sure if it was the
alcohol or whatever but as the game
progressed we all slowly started to
forget the rules this person is most
likely to become famous three two all
one point
[ __ ] oh yeah we all die won't accept a
Volvo just reroute that means to Munich
you know I mean anything I don't know
how this game works okay that was the
last one right Cheers
that's one but it was a success because
you loved that drugs I sell agent people
when they drink more progressively look
like kool-aid specifically me
and what happens is something about our
liver not processing alcohol too well
and I heard it gives us cancer so I'm
good I don't get red so I don't get the
asianglow but uh I can tell that we
should keep filming because I feel like
Davis is progressively going to start
getting super incoherent oh it's already
happening right now everybody knows when
I've had too much to drink because my
words just [ __ ] go all over the place
I slur everything in my mind I'm pretty
I'm pretty cool like I'm speaking all
smooth but I'm pretty sure that's not
how it came in on camera actually this
is the most I've ever drank with David
in my life I think we won't remember we
want yakitori that one time and we just
drink like a bottle of like sake but
that was it
is it this is the most average ring with
David and I'm shocked you know what it
is peer pressure
haha no it's not who's a you know
sometimes you have to unwind and ah this
is a Korean thing but you have to it's
so funny because like when a Korean
person give somebody alcohol the word
note disappears from the English
language it just doesn't exist you'll
tell the Koran person like hey I'm done
drinking
ah you want a little more you have a DUI
a DUI do you mean you drink okay
hey any time how much of the Korean
blanket cost he would what do you call a
baby sheep a sheep Seki ha ha where did
you keep their money alright y'all so
this is the Korean drinking experience
good food good friends great company
that's a good food yes I did what I
meant to say was bombed food but I say
what and undisclosed location we don't
know where we're at but if you come into
place right here when a bunch of
pictures of a bunch of random flowers
and some hieroglyphs of some hookers
then you know where you're at you're at
the best undisclosed restaurant and all
a cop remember
drink responsibly if you're drinking and
driving you're a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
yes because you're not worried about
other people's lies if you're a [ __ ]
drunk driver and you die by yourself who
the [ __ ] cares you're breaking the law
but worry about other people out there
be safe my friends make sure that you
have a cute Korean girlfriend to drive
you home end it with the kiss that is
for camera
it's for camera yeah it's you hey rush
are or have a very beautiful Russian
wife kiss me kiss you
this is good what the [ __ ] man you know
what one of the best ways to top off a
night of drinking and debauchery is to
top it off with a tender kiss from your
girlfriend or your wife but of course if
they won't do it you got to get it from
one of your best friends Justin